c'est un sport extrême aux confins du
street skateboard du bmx freestyle et du
trial moto le défi escalader ride et
jump et des murs ou des grilles bref
tous types d'obstacles urbain sur lequel
effectuer des figures et cela sans
mettre un pied à terre un sport encore
confidentiel qui a pourtant son
championnat du monde depuis dix ans ils
sont une poignée à le pratiquer à la
réunion démonstration
badge à ce sport il est quand même assez
spectaculaire puisque c'est quand même
et on prend beaucoup d'auteurs beaucoup
de plaisir avant tout et
où je m'entraîne sais c'est partout dans
la ville c'est dans la rue quoi c'est dû
street
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec les riders
free trial et street bmx et nous allons
à aider un peu en ville c'est parti
compétition de ce trial ça n'existe pas
du tout à la réunion et en métropole
c'est en train de se développer en
métropole je pense qu'il faut des
autorisations pour rouler ce que là
c'est un sport de rue rouler sur les
lieux publics et ça c'est souvent pas
possibles mais délicieux doit avoir
l'autorisation
au
risque
m
quand je monte sua démarches pour moi
monter toujours plus haut ben ça c'est
un plaisir absolu c'est plus que de la
joie je suis heureux rentrée des
nouvelles figures si tout temps comme ça
et c'est comme ça qu'on progresse il
faut jamais abandonner jamais lâcher les
bras c'est un sport très loin à prendre
mais avec le temps ça vient et ça fait
plaisir
et quand on réussit voilà c'est ça fait
vraiment plaisir on on se sent plus fort
et le niveau augmente de jour en jour
à
on aimerait qu'il y aurait plus de deux
personnes qui puissent rouler avec nous
et donc on the run
nous permet de faire des shows dans
toute l'île pour promouvoir ce sport et
donner l'envié aux gens de rouler avec
nous
bourbon est au chômage
non